- [Narrator] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape:
bipedal, naked, large brain. Long the
master of fire, tools and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is an inevitable, yet
filled with optimism. We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge. We empathize and
deceive. We shape the future from our
shared understanding of the past. CARTA
brings together experts from diverse
disciplines to exchange insights on who we
are and how we got here. An exploration
made possible by the generosity of
humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Richard] I am absolutely thrilled to be
here. But more so I'm thrilled as skin
researcher for the last 20 years and as
chair of the department of dermatology
that this group has decided to focus on
skin and recognize the benefits of this
organ to understand more about who we are
and what ourselves really are made of.
And, of course, the first picture I'd like
to do is to show a couple different hands
that we have in our cover. And these are
the types of hands we like to look at. The
type of skin we like to look at. We have
impressions about ourselves and our health
that's really dictated by the skin. Now,
of course, we recognize ourselves by our
skin. And that's the most obvious function
of all, of what the skin is. There's no
doubt that this is a different species,
perhaps a chimp. And years ago, in the
field of dermatology, there was a very
well-known dermatologist in the name of
William Montagna did quite a bit of
comparative anatomy. Looking at the
histology of different species. And
published a series of fascinating papers
which described many similarities and many
differences between different species in
terms of elements of the skin. And perhaps
what was most interesting about this work
is that this focus of those papers were
really specifically to try to understand
more about ourselves by studying skin
because of primates. Because at that time,
it was easier for him to get primate skin
than it was for him to get human skin. We
also have more rare disorders that, and
somehow, perhaps emphasizes our common
origin, evolutionarily. On the left is an
unfortunate gentleman in China with
something called a large, hairy congenital
nevus. And on the right, is a primate that
has alopecia.
And you wonder if there's some convergence
here, when you look at these types of
photos. And then our government and the
technology-rich world around us exploits
the skin for many things that you may or
may not be aware of. And this is an image
that shows assessing blood flow and
temperature in skin of individuals in an
airport. And it's used actually as a
covert lie detection system to look for
people who might be flushing, nervous. And
it's also used during disease outbreaks
for disease surveillance. This was
particularly prevalent during the SARS
epidemic; trying to pick people who might
have a fever out of a crowd. So the skin
has been exploited by many, many different
ways just from the outside. Sometimes,
looks can be deceiving, and the skin can
fool you. And we take it for granted in
terms of what's going on underneath there.
So I'd like to show you, as skin
biologists, some of the techniques and the
approaches that we use to understand more
about the skin. And to do that, we need to
look more closely what's down deep within
the skin. This is an illustration of what
would happen if you cut a little cube out
of the skin, captured four hair follicles.
The top here is the surface of the skin.
And as we look below the surface, we see
many, many different cell types. In fact,
this is probably the most complex organ
that we have in our body with blood
vessels, nerves, endocrine functions, it
can sweat, it can produce oils, it does
all of this and it must do it in a way
that protects itself from the outside
environment. And as we look more closely,
we see wonderful things going on in these
different cell types within the skin. On
the right, here, is a time-lapse
photography of a live hair follicle
showing how the cells are constantly in
motion, constantly differentiating,
actually regenerating the organ over and
over again. And much of what we've learned
about basic developmental biology, about
stem cells, comes from studying some of
the phenomenal interactions that cells
undergo in this simple little thing of a
hair.
Another way to look at the skin, instead
of cutting through the skin vertically, is
to cut across the top of the surface of
the skin horizontally. And if you did
that, you shave just the top of the skin
and stained what's in there, you see this
network of immune cells. These are called
dendritic cells. And our entire surface of
our skin is covered by this net of cells
that's interacting with the outside
environment. And the classic thoughts
about how those cells interact with the
environment is illustrated in this little
movie. Maybe some of you have seen this.
This actually was a film made in the 1950s
and it was really the dawn of our
understanding of host-immune defense and
how immune cells work. And it shows a
macrophage-like cell, and this little dot
over here, is a bacterium. And it's basic
concept of the time is that we device
specific cells that went out and could
recognize bacteria as bad, as an external
part that we don't want, could chase it
down, as you could see in this movie, the
macrophage is actually changing direction
while it's swimming amongst all these
blood cells and chasing down the bacteria
until it finally can engulf it and kill
it. Well, what we learned about 20 years
ago, now, is that our system that our skin
uses to defend against the outside
environment is more than just specific
cells that are tracking down bacteria. But
that our skin surface also produces
natural antibiotics, we've named these
AMPs, or antimicrobial peptides. And this
is a slide from some work I did when I
was, I guess about 5 years old, because it
was 20 years ago, that shows a brown
staining of the first known mammalian skin
antibiotic.
And this isn't produce by specific immune
cells, but it's actually produced by the
cells that form the surface of the skin,
suggesting that there's more to the way
the skin interacts with the outside
environment that we may otherwise think.
In fact, I want to show you an example of
a wonderful experiment that demonstrates
just how important those surface
antibiotics are to us. And on one side
here, you see a picture of an agar plate
and the way this experiment is done, is
they investigate a very carefully washed
the surface of their hands, touched a
bacteria. And in one case, the bacteria is
Staph.aureus. That's a bacteria that
normally can make infections on the skin.
We know it's dangerous to our skin. And if
you touch those bacteria, wait a few
minutes and then go back later and touch a
plate, you'd see that the bacteria were
able to live on the surface of the skin,
that's why the fingerprints show up, all
those little dots are the bacteria that
lived on the surface of the skin and that
got transferred to the plate. But if you
do the exact same experiment, but now when
you wash your hands instead of touching a
skin bacteria, you touch an intestinal
bacteria like E.coli. This is a pathogen,
too, but it doesn't cause disease in the
skin. You see that when you go back later
and touch your fingers to a plate, all the
E.coli are dead. So this is a great
example and somewhat explains certain
diseases. It explains why Staph.aureus can
be a disease causing organism on skin
because it survives, and why E.coli is
never found as a disease causing organism
in the skin situation, because the skin
makes specific antimicrobials. What's
particularly interesting about this
experiment, though, is the all-important
control. And the scientists love controls.
And that is to do the same experiment but
have sterile surgical gloves on.
So you see what happens, when you have
sterile gloves on and you'd touch
Staph.aureus, and wait a while, and touch
your glove-covered bacteria on the plate,
some of the Staph.aureus survived but
they're not as, they're not doing so well.
They actually missed the fact that they
were on the surface of our skin. But look
at what happened with the E. Coli. These
gloves touched the same number of E.coli
as the bare fingertips did. And you can
see the E.coli survive very, very well
when the gloves are on your hand. So, what
does that mean practically for our
everyday life, thinking about the skin?
Well, it means that gloves protect
bacteria from us. Particularly, bacteria
that cause intestinal diseases. And you
should think about that when you go
through the cafeteria line. So, that's my
segue into some of our research that I
like to talk about, I hope you'll agree
with me, or at least think about the fact
that perhaps how we think about ourselves
as humans shouldn't just be this
antagonistic relationship between us
defending against them. But as you'll hear
later in the afternoon, there's quite a
bit of information that's coming from the
field of microbiome research that says
that these bacteria that are on us,
perhaps they're not all so bad. And is it
possible that a lot of the skin bacteria
that normally survive on us are not just
bystanders? And what I want to lead to is
to ask you to think about the question,
"Should we really completely rethink
established approaches to the study of
human origin based on these observations
made in the skin?" Classically, we think
about this type of tree of life in
evolution where single-cell organisms
evolved into complex organisms like
humans.
But I propose to you, that perhaps we
should flip this on it's head and think
about it, really, that we have evolved to
serve the master microbes. And we're all
these little different types of organisms,
some dropped off the evolutionary tree,
and some survive. But we're here, in part,
to serve the microbe and perpetuate it's
survival. And I think you would agree that
with the expansion of humans, the
expansion of the microbes that we carry is
going to be just as successful, so it's
good for them, too. So what's the evidence
to support this kind of crazy thinking?
Well, has human skin and microbe really
co-evolved to serve each other? Are the
microbes one of our own cells, not just
something foreign, but is this part of us?
And there's lots of evidence now to
really, I think, very clearly show us that
specific types of bacteria, specific
microbes on the skin are absolutely
essential to human health. How could this
be? Well, one way we understood this is
when we realize that the microbes aren't
just living outside on the surface.
They're not outside the door but they're
really integral in that little piece of
skin that I illustrated to you earlier.
This is some work done by a couple of
scientists in my lab over the last few
years showing how microbes are not just at
the surface, and that's these little tiny
purple dots, and the epidermis is the top
layer of the skin. And if you look down in
the hair follicle, you see lots of
microbes, that wasn't such a surprise. But
what was a surprise to us and many others
is that if you look in areas that we
thought were sterile, even in healthy skin
that hasn't been injured, that's normally
working, there's collections of microbes
that live down amongst our inner fat, in
the tissues between our blood vessels. And
they're there in a place where they could
be interacting with the rest of our body.
One of the ways that microbes benefit us
on our skin can be illustrated by an
experiment just like the one I showed you
before, but with a little bit of a twist.
So, this is an experiment, again those
three lines are fingertips. And now the
investigator was a graduate student in my
lab, Anna Cogen, who washed her hands very
carefully of the normal bacteria and
touched a type of bacteria known as Group
A Streptococcus. This is also known as the
flesh-eating bacteria. So normal ones
would be very dangerous. This was a type
of bacteria that we attenuated so it's
relatively safe. Well, why we used these
bacteria is that they are a pathogen, so
they're a foreign bacteria, we don't want
them. And secondly, that they have a
unique capacity to lyse red blood cells.
So, you can see them really obviously when
you touch a plate that has blood in it. It
lyses it, that's why it's all clear. So
what happens if she has on her fingertips
not the bad guys, the flesh-eating
bacteria, but these are normal fingertips
colonized with a type of bacteria that you
all have on your skin right now at a
concentration of somewhere between 10,000
and 100,000 per square centimeter. You
have a lot of these bacteria, known as
Staph.epidermidis, epidermis for the skin.
So these are not disease, this isn't
dirty, this was normal. And if you touch
this plate with skin that's populated with
those, you can see those bacteria because
they make these little tiny dots here,
shadows. So now, here's the question. What
happens if Anna, instead of washing her
hands really carefully before touching the
flesh-eating bacteria, just had let the
normal bacteria survive on her skin, the
healthy type of bacteria? Well, this is
what happens. She touched the same amount
of bacteria, it's on the far right here.
But now, in this case with your healthy
bacteria there, it's fighting, it's
helping you resist the flesh-eating
bacteria. And she'd gone on to actually
identify new antibiotics from these types
of bacteria.
And there are many hundreds of new
antibiotics that can be discovered just
within our own ecosystem, on our surface
of the skin. Another way that bacteria
control us, is they influence how much of
a rash, or how much inflammation you can
have. And this is a very dramatic
experiment, again, using this model of the
skin cartoon that shows if you cut your
skin or scratch your skin, and it's
absolutely sterile and you have no
bacteria on it, the amount of swelling and
redness and scaliness is much, much
greater than if the skin has a normal
microbiome. And you can see that here in
this microscopic image how thick a sterile
wound it as opposed to non-infected but a
normal skin wound with a normal microbial
community. So the microbes are defending
us against flesh-eating bacteria, some
microbes are controlling our immune
system. And this is some very recent work
that we've done to look at a very common
type of disease known as atopic
dermatitis. Here's a picture of a child in
the corner here on the bottom with a
complication of this disease. It's a type
of eczema and these patients
unfortunately, very often get
Staph.infections, that was that bacteria
that we showed you in the glove
experiment. And when you look at normal
population, this is several thousand
samples, most of the normal bacteria on
healthy individuals produce these
antibiotics that kill Staphylococcus
disease causing bacteria. But in patients
with eczema, there's very few, actually,
of the normal type of bacteria. They're
displaced by another bacteria. It's
neither disease causing, nor normal. It's
kind of inert. It doesn't do us any good.
And when that happens, these individuals
then start to get Staph.infections.
There's a very, very strict correlation
between the capacity to get a
Staph.infection and whether or not you
have these bacteria.
So, what can you do with this type of
realization? Well, you can try to help
people, which is ultimately why we do our
research. And this is showing an
experiment, this is beginning of a large
clinical trial, we're doing a number of
cities. This is now eight patients, but
kind of show you what happens. This is the
average result. And on the blue side is
before treatment. And then amount of
Staph.aureus. And the red side is after
you put a treatment on. So, first is the
control, you just put a moisturizing cream
on. And you see the amount of the infected
bacteria, if anything it goes up a little
bit, doesn't really change. And what if
you put one of these inert bacteria like
are found in patients with the disease?
Oh, nothing happens. If you put a cream
that has those bacteria on it, the
patients stay the same, they still have
less, a lot of Staph.aureus. But now
here's strain two. This is a bacterial
strain from a normal person, that's
transplanted onto the disease skin. And
you can see this bacterial strain just in
a single application causes over 100 fold
decrease in the amount of infectious
bacteria. This has worked actually to
every single patient we tried so far. So
we better stop the study now, right?
Before we find out it doesn't work. But
we're very excited about it. And I think
it's further showing how some microbes,
not all microbes, are our friends. And
some microbes are clearly our enemies. So,
how should be think about this in this
conference? Well, I'd like to propose to
you the concept of the super organism. We
probably only inherit, of our total
genetic makeup in our bodies, probably
only about 10% of it really comes from our
parents, because 90% of the organisms that
we carry around from us are microbes. So
that means, when you think about it, most
of the genetic material we're carrying
around, we can exchange. We're not stuck
with the things our parents gave us. We
can exchange bacteria just by shaking
hands. And if anybody is really healthy
here, I'd like to shake hands with you.
And what it really also means of course,
we realize this already, but our
environment can directly influence who we
are. And this now starts to get us to a
molecular and genetic explanation for
something we've observed for a very long
time. Certain environmental situations
affect health and that might be because
those environmental situations are
affecting the health of the cells on us
that are microbes. So with that, I'd like
to suggest that understanding the pro- and
anti-microbial systems of primates and
humans can better define who we are. And
thank you very much for your time.
♪ [music] ♪